[Music]
[Applause]
we spent a little bit of time talking
about the Memphis Grizzlies and Dylan
Brooks is not going to be back with this
team and the beat rider for the Memphis
Grizzlies for the daily memphian Drew
Hill joins us on the program Drew thanks
for joining us
um take us back to maybe at the All-Star
break felt like the Grizzlies were
trying to replace Dylan Brooks without
officially announcing that they were
trying to trade for somebody else uh is
that true
yeah and I think there was actually some
frustration there
um
it is not often that you hear a general
manager come out and say hey we tried
you know uh we we gave our best effort
we offered deals that we thought were
above and beyond what anybody else would
offer and it just didn't work out nobody
would take any of them but that's
essentially what the Memphis Grizzlies
did they were rumored in deals for OG
and Obi they were ruperted deals for
McHale Bridges offering as many as four
draft picks for him three first round
draft picks for OG and Adobe people
thought the deals were kind of
ridiculous that Memphis was offering a
lot neither team takes it and I think
you heard general manager Zach climbed
in it he obviously didn't speak on any
of the specifics of any of the rumored
deals but he did come out and say you
know we were really Ultra aggressive at
this deadline and we just couldn't get a
deal to go through and uh so yeah they
they've been trying to make an upgrade
at that Wing position for a while now
and they haven't really made it much of
a secret how did it go over locally when
you had M say quoting uh that Dylan was
not going to be back under any or any
circumstances here
I think people here were ready to move
on from Dylan Brooks now Dylan certainly
has his fans here and he's the longest
tenure Grizzly uh coming into this
season he's one of just two holdovers
from the Marc Gasol Mike Conley era so
that had made him a a liked figure here
in Memphis
but the way that the last two playoffs
have gone particularly the series
against Golden State now the series
against the the Lakers
it really soured people here
um I think a good bit and so for Dylan I
think it's just better for both sides to
move on and you could sort of hear and
feel that disconnect as this series sort
of continued and it became more and more
frustrating for him but but Drew are we
looking at the end result here if
Memphis wins that Series against the
Lakers are the Memphis fans still okay
with Dylan Brooks is management okay
with Dylan Brooks
I I think that's a good question and
that's a fair question but I think the
management still this summer is going
out and looking for a way to upgrade on
the wing Dylan Brooks is not an
efficient shooter he doesn't exactly fit
what they need to do with their core of
three players moving forward
he's a good Defender he gets a lot of
credit for the defense that he plays he
did not play great defense in that
Series against the Lakers the Grizzlies
found out that Xavier Tillman was better
on LeBron James than Dylan Brooks was so
if if the Grizzlies are solving problems
and throwing Dylan Brooks out of the
equation then moving forward it's not
that difficult to throw Dylan Brooks out
of the equation I wonder when he
embraced this sort of Draymond Green
Light that I'm I'm gonna I'm getting
coverage now when you're scoring 18
you're a nice player you're never going
to be the focal point of that team but
it's almost like he'd rather average 14
and be a villain uh or tough guy or
instigator and then it kind of blew up
in his face
you know this is really flipped two
years ago I was in Utah it was uh
covered year and so we were doing phone
interviews back then and this was right
when the Dylan the villain nickname was
starting to take off and I asked him
over the phone if he liked the Dylan
Villa nickname now this is a nickname
that dates back to when he was in
college at Oregon so this is It's been
around but it really picked up at that
time
wooden fans were booing the heck out of
him in Utah
and he was not sold on the deal on the
villain nickname okay he said he he
somewhat liked the dill in the villain
nickname but he didn't see himself as a
villain that's two years ago now he's
completely leaned into this villain
image this villain uh sort of narrative
that's around him and it's obvious that
he's leaning into it because of the
Antics on the court you know he this is
a guy that's going after Theo Pinson for
standing up on the bench Theo Pinson a
guy who's not even playing in the game
for the Dallas Mavericks uh and getting
in a technical foul that ends up with
this Dylan being suspended for another
game like this is a guy that has not
really seemed to care what other people
think of him and has really leaned into
this whole image thing uh and did
obviously did what he did with LeBron
James and so this has been a change over
two years for Dylan Brooks I think some
of it is has been frustrating for the
Grizzlies in the Grizzlies front office
um and some of it is stuff that you what
you you want to have a player that will
do those sort of things and will be your
heart and soul and will be the guy
that'll go to battle against the other
team's best player every single night
and some of it becomes too much and I
think at some point for Dylan it just
became too much
John Morant this off season
um
are we holding our breath here like can
he can he be quiet can it be a quiet
off-season for John Morant
I can only say obviously I'm not with
John Moran on his in his day-to-day life
so I don't want to come on here and say
I think John Moran's completely changed
he's flipping like that would be
it would be smart it's not a smart thing
to say but what I can say is
I believe that the Grizzlies believe
that he's making the right steps forward
and from my perspective
being in the locker room for media
availabilities talking to jaw uh off the
court
the the way that he's addressed those
things and the conversations has already
changed
um he's he knows and he's very aware of
some of the headlines that are going to
be out there or that are out there and
the opportunities for him uh to be put
on front page news one thing that I did
notice uh he was asked by a reporter
that is not typically a Grizzlies beat
reporter wasn't really following the
team in the playoffs but had really
popped in at the end uh when the season
ended after game six and he was asked
about the honest quote about failure
and Ja pretty much shot it down right
away and said you know I I get it it was
a great quote but I don't want to be put
on this I don't want to be on these
headlines like I I respectfully I'm just
gonna leave that to be honest I don't
wanna we would never get an answer like
that from job maybe a half a year ago
six months ago
um and so he I think he's learning
really to to kind of dial it back and
he's done a very good job of that over
the last few months and I asked him are
you proud of yourself for doing that uh
at the exit interviews and he said yeah
less job on the blogs that's that's my
goal less jaw on the blogs so I think
that at least with the media he's going
to be able to do that whether he stays
out of the headlines completely this
summer I mean I don't I can't say I I
don't follow him in his day-to-day life
Drew thanks for joining us hopefully you
have an uneventful off-season but uh
thanks for joining us yeah thanks Dan
appreciate it that's uh Drew Hill it
covers the Grizzlies for the Daily
memphian